eeuu busca atajar el avance de la
viruela del mundo con miles de casos y
estados de emergencia sanitaria
declarados en lugares como california y
nueva york- el presidente joe biden
nombró a altos funcionarios de la
agencia federal para el manejo de
emergencias y de los centros para el
control y la prevención de enfermedades
para reforzar la vacunación y frenar la
propagación de la viruela del mono y es
que como en eeuu las cifras de la
enfermedad siguen en aumento en el mundo
hay más de 23.000 casos confirmados
según el rastreo del global health y se
calcula que ya ha llegado a al menos 80
países una de las situaciones más
críticas la enfrenta europa en españa el
segundo de la lista ya son 4300 los
casos conocidos y alemania tiene dos mil
677 le sigue reino unido con dos mil 469
contagios y francia con dos mil 171
contagios
asia por su parte reportó la primera
muerte por viruela del mono este lunes
un joven de 22 años falleció en india
según las autoridades el paciente no
presentaba los síntomas cutáneos
visibles en la piel que suelen
caracterizar la enfermedad su caso
continúa siendo estudiado por el
departamento de salud ha establecido un
comité de alto nivel que incluye a
miembros de la junta médica estatal y
realizaremos investigaciones detalladas
además las autoridades de salud del
distrito local están tomando las medidas
apropiadas de acción américa latina no
es la excepción los más afectados brasil
con 978 casos y perú con 305 en los dos
se han reportado una muerte por la
enfermedad
lado ms declaró el actual brote de la
viruela del mundo como emergencia de
salud pública de nivel internacional el
23 de julio y unos días después dijo que
por ahora se descartaba recomendar la
vacunación masiva sino más bien una
dirigida para enfrentar su propagación